- When you actually believe
in the value you're providing,
selling, promoting, giving for free,
when you believe, it all clicks.
The reason people don't do is because
they don't believe.
They either are insecure
and structured that way
or they deep down know they're
doing it for the money.
("Vigilante" by Jan Ace)
ONE37PM is just looking at
men's culture 15 to 55, the
mindset, the grind, the hustle,
health and wellness, fashion,
music, sports, culture,
entrepreneurship, mindset, positivity,
I'm so fuckin' fired up about ONE37PM.
Actually you know what?
I'm gonna actually ask for a favor.
It matters a lot to me.
I think we're, it's gonna be a big deal
as you can imagine and
it would mean a lot to me
if you guys could share ONE37PM today.
I just posted on Twitter, the big article,
if you can go and retweet that,
that would mean the world to me
or if you could post the
URL or pass on the site,
it would mean so much to me,
this is something we've
been working on for a year.
The ONE37PM Instagram right now
has a ton of cool shit on it.
On Instagram, it's the word
spelt out, three, seven P, M.
Alright guys I gotta go into this event,
actually this'll be fun.
So these peeps really won because they,
they won the breakfast.
Alright, this is the breakfast crew?
- Breakfast crew.
What's up Gary?
- Part of the breakfast club?
- How you doing?
- Good to see ya.
- Good to see you too.
- All good?
- We were just stalking you.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
Hey.
- Gary, good to meet you man.
- It's a pleasure.
Hi, how are you?
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- How are things?
Sit, sit, sit.
Congrats guys.
- Thank you.
- You guys won the, you won the game.
Alright Instagram, I'm outta here.
This is the crew that, what do you got?
You guys won the 10 books?
- The things that motivate
me, motivated me from before,
kind of don't motivate me now.
- Of course.
- Is this ever something that
you struggled with and
do you have any advice?
- Oh I don't think it's a struggle,
I think it's an accomplishment.
(chuckling)
If you're in a place
where you're motivated by,
do you know how many people
live 88 years of their lives
motivated by money and
never get away from it
because they achieved the money.
- Right, interesting.
- You know how many
people are motivated by
you chase the fame for
92 years of their life
and never stop because
they never got famous?
- Right.
- Like, this is such a fun,
this is what this is about.
That is such a subtle terminology shift.
You've been looking at it as a negative.
It's a massive, it's a massive positive.
- Absolutely, yeah and like I said, I--
- Like, I'll, I apologize
but I wanna frame it for you.
Like I'm secretly worried
that I'm gonna get to a place
where I'm not gonna care
anything about business
and it's the love of my life.
But I can like feel it
already, I'm like, ooof.
You know 55 to 75 is gonna be some run.
When you actually believe in
the value you're providing,
selling, promoting, giving for free.
When you believe, it all clicks.
The reason people don't do is
because they don't believe.
They either are insecure
and structured that way
or they deep down know they're
doing it for the money.
You know how many people like
did things for me with expectation?
A ton.
And most of the times I'll say no
because I don't even wanna do that.
But once in awhile I say yes.
Mainly to stick it to them
and teach them a life lesson.
Which is don't come at me and be like
I wanna do this awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around
and always have this
weird relationship with me
where they expect something
like we did something here.
Like, if you told me upfront
that the reason you bought
10 thousand books and did this thing
was because what you really
wanted was my fuckin' face
on your website co-signing
your bullshit business,
well then you shoulda told me,
'cause then we coulda had a transaction.
I might wanna sneak in Maribel.
Hold on, nope, Todd Ruth.
Call my friend, wish him and
his son good luck this weekend.
I'm so glad you caught all of that.
Yeah guys this is how my world works.
You think you're going
to one thing and then
you're calling Todd Ruth.
I love it, I love doing
surprise and delight
from social media.
Follow me on Twitter.
- [Todd] Hey, this is Todd.
- Todd, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Todd] Gary what's going on man?
- Life is good man, I
wanted to take a minute
and wish you guys luck in
the tournament this weekend.
- [Todd] We really appreciate it man.
It's gonna be a good weekend.
- Are you guys gonna win it?
- [Carter] Yeah, yeah we're gonna win.
- Who's that?
What's your name man?
- [Carter] Carter Ruth.
- Carter, it's a real pleasure bro.
I hope you guys, so you're positive Carter
you fuckin' got this?
This is like on lock, you're gonna win it?
- [Carter] Yeah, we're gonna win.
- Where are you with the podcast?
- It's doing great.
- How often?
- Once, twice a week.
- More.
- Okay.
- Facebook?
- I'm more on Instagram.
- Do what I do.
- Okay.
- You can literally leave right now.
Just do everything I'm doing, all of it.
LinkedIn, Facebook, Twitter,
Email, Text, fuckin' just,
you know how I always say
like watch what I'm doing
not what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Just do everything
I'm doing, it will work.
The bigger part that you have to do,
that's the right, that's the right thing.
What you fill it with is gonna be
the variable of your success.
I'm giving you the right cup.
- I got that, I got that covered.
- Good.
What I tell people to
do is get the leverage.
You know, let them go to
your Instagram and see
10 thousand people there
in an active community.
Let them hear that you're selling out
every time you have a new thing.
Then they're gonna come to you.
The thing I do extremely
well, all the fancy people,
every fancy person you've
ever seen me with, anyone,
Tony, The Rock, anyone, any one.
I've never reached out to them.
Let everything come to you, all of them.
Thanks guys, I gotta run.
- [Everybody] Thank you Gary.
- When people talk to me
about this space I'm like,
you've gotta understand like,
this is just a talent game.
Because no matter how much
network with me or Ferriss
or fuckin' whatever right?
If you're not good on stage
then you're not good on stage.
- Yup.
- And you have all the advantages like,
life is a funny game isn't it?
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like, you're gonna have all the advantages
'cause of your story.
You're like on third base.
Now you just have to deliver on stage.
Everything else will work out
and if you're producing
content and building awareness
and Jay being with people and building up
that brand association,
the number one thing
I would tell you is just
make sure you're patient.
Clearly, here's where you fuck up.
In your impatience, you
build the wrong relationships
with the people that you need
to have relationships with.
The amount of people that no longer
have a relationship with
me because they were just
hungry for money in the short term,
or weren't looking to have a relationship,
they were just looking to
siphon from me, game over.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So as long as you deploy, look how,
collective five years, five of
you are like younger than me.
Like you got time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So we're all underdogs
here, actually for us four
and for me growing up, I
was bullied in high school.
I was 4'11" freshman year
and I'm gassing up too
but what I really love is
your underdog mentality.
How do you keep that momentum going
and everything else going?
- You know what's funny?
I don't know.
Meaning, it just has not
been able to leave me.
But I'm not so sold, I
think the biggest thing
and I don't, when I say I don't know,
here's what I can tell you.
When people gas me the
fuck up, I don't hear it.
- Yeah.
- And I also watch like
when fuckin' Prince dies,
in 24 hours nobody gave a fuck ever again
or Maya Angelou or things of that nature,
I'm like okay, let's like, you know
let's not get too crazy here.
No matter how much
impact you're gonna have,
you'll have your, if you're a killer,
you'll have a day, a day
and a half of the internet
giving you love or whatever
the internet is of the time
and then they'll be
all back to like right?
Like, Anthony Bourdain is not coming out
of anybody's mouth anymore.
So you get your time, he obviously had,
you know I was really impressed,
he really affected a lot of people.
That was real right?
But also it's timing.
Like if there's a war breaking
out or the economy collapses
and you happen to die at that minute,
or like a royal wedding
like you get washed out.
So like for me it's kind of like,
yeah.
It's humility.
The underdog mentality
matures into a humility
that's important.
Can you get Alex?
I know I'm gonna be fuckin'
late for this meeting.
I wanna spend more time with
you guys 'cause you know,
one thing I play on is
intuition and I really do.
The reason I'm pushing
you on the other thing is,
I don't want you guys
to have any levels of
full of shit in you 'cause you will win.
I genuinely think that it's not bad thus
I'm trying to make you feel
comfortable to be okay.
I go around and say I'm
gonna buy the New York Jets.
As somebody who cares
about money the least
out of every fucker, I'm the
one with the biggest like,
I'm gonna buy this but you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yup, yeah.
- Buy you guys know I'm better
'cause you can see how I act.
Do you understand?
Just keep it mind.
Cool, alright Alex.
We have that person and
then I have to go right?
- [Alex] Yes.
- Cool.
("Vigilante" by Jan Ace)